[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute apple
crumble liebe apple crumble und
irgendwie passt das für mich so ein
bisschen in die herbst winter saison
natürlich geht es auch im sommer aber
ich finde einfach winter ist michael
zeit und daher zeige ich euch jetzt wie
das ganz einfach selber machen könnte es
ist wirklich ein witz rezept denn ich
habe jetzt hier schon meine äpfel die
habe ich schon in kleine stückchen
geschichte nimmt am besten säuerliche
äpfel und ich las die schale auch immer
dran für mich hat das so ein bisschen
bratapfel charakter und das gibt jetzt
schon direkt in meine auflaufform so die
äpfel in der form gibt es ganz kurz zur
seite wenn ihr nicht möchte dass die
braun werden ich meine es beeinträchtigt
denn ich den geschmack aber die optik
ist auch wichtig dann gibt einfach ein
bisschen zitronensaft oben drüber und
jetzt habe ich hier die zutaten für
meine streusel und die vermisse ich
jetzt einfach mit den händen
das sind einmal brown hat zucker kommt
auch rohrzucker nehmen dann habe ich
hier zimmer warme butter ein bisschen
zimt mail und wir den besonderen klick
möchtet dann nimmt noch ein paar
amerikas
[Musik]
jetzt habt ihr die streusel masse fertig
und ich gebe da jetzt noch für das
gewisse extra maritimes rein einfach so
mit den händen zu verprügeln und wer die
nicht mag der lässt sich einfach
ersatzlos weg also eigentlich müsste es
ja maritime heißen oder am maritim ist
es doch falsch okay gut also wir sind
jetzt so weit fertig bin ich treu sind
und geben das jetzt einfach auf die
äpfel den ofen und übrigens auch schon
vor gehalt das könnt ihr direkt machen
das ist eine regelrechte blitz rezept
meine lieben also einfach drauf geben
und dann bei 200 grad ober und
unterhitze im vorgeheizten backofen so
ungefähr 25 bis 30 minuten backen
[Musik]
and that's it so schnell könnt ihr euer
eigenes apple crumble machen und wenn
ihr jetzt nicht gerade kalorien zählt
dann drückt mir eingefallen gibt da eine
portion vanille eis drauf und
karamellsoße also schon ein grad ich
freue mich richtig weil ich das gleich
genießen werde auf der couch und euch
wünsche ich jetzt ganz viel spaß ja es
sind ja das ist wirklich so schön hallte
sollte das echt mal ausprobieren falls
doch mal auf instagram da seht ihr dann
das haben sie das mal ausprobieren
könnte beziehungsweise ihr seid echt
okay wir sind echt viel privates auf
instagram freut uns gerne auf instagram
ich schreibe ich hier rein ansonsten in
die bisherigen geschaut habt ihr wisst
bescheid gibt es ein bäumchen nach oben
macht weiß ich nach und schauten die
infobox für die genauen mengenangaben
und dann würde ich mal sagen bis zum
nächsten mal auf die sketche immer
gleich mit dir
[Musik]